Monday morning in the business district
of Amanda it's a sad sight whole
neighborhoods of the biggest city in the
region have come to a standstill most
businesses remain closed green grocer
Roberts isn't opening his shop today
even though he badly needs to it is a
very difficult situation to imagine that
on a deal like this some of us will live
on a daily bread meaning that today
there is no bread today there is no
break but we adapt because it's a course
that were fighting for Robert says he
hasn't seen any development in the
region even though he regularly pays his
taxes he and others are protesting by
not opening their businesses and they
are also calling for the release of a
number of demonstrators in the mostly
english-speaking West of Cameroon many
people feel marginalized they feel
they've been forgotten by President Paul
BR and the french-speaking majority of
the country in late 2016 lawyers took to
the streets to protests teachers soon
followed suit then finally people from
all walks of life the authorities
responded with a heavy hand at least six
people died and dozens were arrested
internet access in the region was
blocked for three months we try to talk
to the governor here about the situation
but he didn't grant us an interview a
government spokesperson told us on the
phone that actions are more important
than words and that they are working on
the situation but many people we talk to
here are complaining that there is no
serious dialog happening instead parts
of the population become more radical
businesses owned by people who did not
take part in the protest are often the
target of arson attacks we talked to a
young man who wants to remain anonymous
he himself was almost arrested he wants
the region to become independent and he
thinks the use of violence is legitimate
because he doesn't think the government
would allow a referendum
it's a necessary evil I wouldn't say
citing people's properties on fire is a
good thing but it's a necessary evil as
of now if I have to tell you everything
that runs through my head I might look
like a terrorist to you but I'm not a
terrorist
but when you look at the frustration
when the frustration mounts to a certain
extent you cannot contain you become
radical that's what happens we're just
hoping that sometime soon somebody will
come and say here are the guns you need
take them and fight for your freedom and
we will do just that
the mood in the city is tense divisions
between radicals and moderates have
widened the church has tried to mediate
and is calling on all parties to engage
in a dialogue the mine or the question
of the church is very clear that
violence is not to be encouraged but at
the same time the church stands for
justice
that people should be treated according
to their rights they should be given
fair hearing and that they should be
able to be listened to and if they have
difficulties of grievances that these
could be looked into so that we can have
a lasting solution Roberts the
greengrocer is also hoping that there
will be a peaceful resolution and that
the government finally responds schools
have been closed for almost a year now
and his kids have been affected Robert
says the current situation cannot
continue